donc ibrahim c'est plutôt des bonnes
nouvelles et moi au nom de la production
à mon nom sachez que vous serez logés à
l'hôtel à mes frais dès ce soir
voilà donc ce soir où sera l'hôtel las
et voilà c'est pour nous jusqu'à voilà
pendant pendant un an
voilà voilà histoire de repartir
[Applaudissements]
merci merci brahim si vous voulez
vraiment vous donner un coup de pouce et
j'espère que vous allez pouvoir repartir
et pour pouvoir travailler merci braille
je le veux de toute façon une fois que
j'ai mes papiers
abb n'a toujours l'oreille maple tout le
temps mais c est nous donne du boulot
j'ai pas de compte pas le papier tout ce
que j'ai sûrement l'asema cap
professionnel j'ai tout ce que j'ai pu
justement je veux vraiment que pour
l'instant vous soyez à l'hôtel vous
enleviez déjà ce problème est que vous
fassiez vos papiers avec le ministère du
logement puisque ils vont s'occuper de
vous et comme ça on peut avancer et vous
allez pouvoir retravailler et vous
remettre
voilà sur les bons rails voilà merci
ibrahim parce que c'est grâce à eux on a
pu voir le cas d'ibrahim merci mike
ibrahim je m'occupe de vous je vous
lâche pas voilà merci beaucoup en tout
cas